PRESIDENT NOW WAKING IT CLEAR
WHY WE ARE PAYING THAT U.N.
ORGANIZATION SO MUCH AND FUNDING
IT.
TONIGHT, SENATOR GRAHAM IS
BUILDING A BIPARTISAN COALITION
IN THE SENATE TO CALL ON CHINA
TO SHUT DOWN ITS SO-CALLED WET
MARKETS WHICH CAUSE NOT JUST
THIS PANDEMIC BUT ARE BREEDING
GROUNDS FOR FUTURE ONES.
HE JOINS US NOW.
I THINK THAT IS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
THE U.K. STUDY SHOWED 95% OF
THIS COULD’VE BEEN PREVENTED.
>> THE FIRST THING I WANT TO DO
IS GET THE UNITED STATES SENATE
ON THE RECORD WHERE WE, WE DON’T
BLAME TRUMP, WE BLAME CHINA.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR 16,000 AMERICAN
DEATHS AND 17 MILLION AMERICANS
BEING UNEMPLOYED, IT’S THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND THE WAY
THEY BEHAVE THAT LED TO THIS
PANDEMIC.
THIS IS THE THIRD ONE TO COME
OUT OF CHINA.
I WANT TO MAKE OUR RESPONSE TO
THIS SO OVERWHELMING THAT CHINA
WILL CHANGE ITS BEHAVIOR, I WANT
TO GET THE MEDICAL SUPPLY CHAIN
BACK INTO THE UNITED STATES AND
I WANT TO STOP COUNSELING SOME
DEBT THAT WE OWE TO CHINA
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD BE PAYING
US.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE A
BIPARTISAN PUSH BACK AGAINST
CHINA TO PUNISH THEM SO SEVERELY
TO DETERMINE DETER THEM IN THE F
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK IF
WERE GOING TO GET THE COUNTRY UP
AND RUNNING AND WE’RE GOING TO
DO IT SAFELY.
ABBOTT CAME UP WITH A FIVE
MINUTE TEST, --
>> THAT’S LONGER THAN I GET ON
YOUR SHOW.
>> Sean: YOU TOOK ONE BEFORE
YOU GOT ON THE SHOW?
IF THEY CAN SOMEHOW GET OTHER
COUNTRIES MASS-PRODUCING THIS,
TO ME, THAT’S THE KEY TO DOING
IT SAFELY AND SECURELY.
>> THURSDAY TWO KINDS OF TESTS,
DO YOU HAVE IT OR HAVE YOU HAD
AT?
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE HAD IT AND
DON’T KNOW IT, WE NEED TO TEST
THEM AND GET THEM BACK TO WORK
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOOD TO GO AND
WE NEED TESTS TO SHOW THEY DON’T
IT RIGHT NOW.
IF WE ARE GOING TO GET THE
ECONOMY BACK OPEN SAFELY AND THE
WAY TO DO IT DOES HAVE A TESTING
MACHINE THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK SAFELY.
BETTER DAYS LIE AHEAD.
>> Sean: SENATOR, THANK YOU.
WE NEED THOSE TESTS, AS MANY AS